Okay, so what's a bag?
A bag is a container having
the following properties, and
these properties will
make it just perfect for
holding the frontier
in our parallel BFS.
First, a bag will be unordered and
will allow repetition.
Remember that a BFS has to
maintain a frontier, so
it enables as much
parallelism as possible,
we should allow redundant insertions
of the same vertex if need be.
So here, for example,
you can see that this bag has
three copies of the element c,
and that's okay, why?
Because even if we process
c at the same time, by say,
different threads They should
all get assigned the same level.
Now the second thing a bag will allow
is fast denumeration of its elements.
Remember, the BFS has to traverse
all the vertices in the frontier, so
being able to do so
quickly will be extremely helpful.
Now, also remember that our best
parallelization technique so
far has been divide and conquer.
So one really special operation on a bag
is the idea of splitting it into two
roughly equal pieces.
And, of course, the inverse operation
should also be fast, and that's union.
Now union will also be special in that
it will be logically associative.
So what does that mean?
Suppose I call this A and I call this B.
Logical associativity means that A union
B is exactly the same as B union A,
at least logically even if that's
not physically how we store things.
Now logical associativity will
also give us the property or
the ability to apply
reducer hyperobjects.